sixty years in broadcasting if not
longer a long time Dodger fan legendary
broadcaster Larry came joining us on the
program good morning Larry how are you
good morning Dan and how are you I'm
doing great I hear you're on your way to
the airport because you're gonna go see
Game three in Houston I am in the
vehicle with my two sons and we are
heading to the airport for three four
and five
nice nice are you hoping it goes seven
I'm a Dodger fan hoping it goes five I
I've been through a lot of World Series
not to a lot but through a lot I know
you never it's never over when it was
over last year the Indians about three
games to one nothing is secure every
pitch is painful Wednesday night was one
of the best and worst nights ever had a
ballpark in my life
but that's baseball that's why it's a
great sport and I'm hoping now if it
goes no I wanted to go five and we win I
like to win in Houston but I really want
to get back home I think we got to
definitely win one game in years
what how long have you had those seats
behind home plate six seven years I used
to have him for every game and then as
the boys got a little older and they're
away at school without every other game
for the past two years so instead of
every game about every other name first
and the playoffs and World Series first
baseball game you ever went to my father
died and on June 9th 1943 I was nine and
a half
my brother was six and a half and my
uncle Bernie was the Yankee bullpen
catcher was a part time job
it would only catch at home it was a
regular job and he took me to on July 1
I must forget the day but July 1943 I
just played the Reds we won four to
three I'll never forget walking into his
field the only description I ever had it
was
red Barbara's voice and I saw the game
through his voice and it was incredible
of it how green the grass was how brown
the dirt was the white lines that to me
it was huge in his field which is a
small wall Park was huge and I fell in
love with it going in but I fell in love
ever since first big-time baseball
player you meant was who first big-time
baseball player I met was when I'm going
down in Miami
to break into broadcasting I met all the
circuit 1959-60 the all the Orioles
Orioles train there you know so I saw a
guy start I saw Murray start Ripken
Brooks those brave Oriole teams and
actually became an oil fan because when
I started on the mutual network I moved
to Washington and the closest team with
33 miles was Memorial Stadium and that
we've been away and sooth and on the
team was one of my best friends I went
to a lot of oil games and sadly I will
admit that I rooted for the Orioles when
they played the Los Angeles Dodgers and
swept them in the World Series Jim
Palmer was a great friend and however as
soon as I moved that I would to
Washington in Washington with 20 years
rule for the Orioles went to their games
and then I moved out to LA for the
simpson trial stayed in LA got married
had two boys there now 18 and 17 both
baseball players took them to Dodger
games when they were three and two and
weary romance my love of Dodger blue but
when so you relocated to Los Angeles to
do your show just because of the OJ
trial they brought me out here to cover
the OJ problem the OJ trial is how many
months yes we did so many shows and so
many panels I knew everybody on the road
yeah the prosecutors I knew the
attorneys I live that trial and and
right at the end of it right at the end
met my wife and like Los Angeles and CNN
said the spine works as well for the
West Coast there's beautiful studios in
West Coast so I skate and I wound up at
CNN for almost 26 years if you give
advice and often students will ask me
for advice but is there one piece of
advice for a young interviewer that you
would give yeah put your ego at the door
no that's not that's not the fashion
today today too many it's the
interviewer counts more than the
interviewee which I always thought was
terrible so if you could good to clever
good advice a short questions follow-up
listen to the answers because the answer
will bring you possibly the next
question and leave yourself out of it in
technically I go for my style I the word
I interview is irrelevant so the way you
were doing this interview which was
perfectly bad had you said the new
modern fashion would have been ID and
Patrick saw my first game on this of
this date I went with my cousin the this
team beat that game what was yours Larry
yeah now use your there every day it's
your show you spent two minutes getting
an answer that you want from your guest
but you're talking about yourself and
it's the interviewer is not an eye
person the interviewer is a wire person
if I can give you one more interview who
would it be
oh my god my wish was to tell Castro and
he he passed away I guess it would be in
how Merkel she's the most powerful woman
in Germany mm-hmm and most awful person
in Germany
Germany has become a key figure in all
of Europeans settings I would take for
Anna for baseball I would take jose
altuve
lifelink is a real loving a remarkable
person but it absolutely flat-out
remarkable athlete I hope he doesn't get
another hit
but I have never had never seen someone
he's not five six by the way daddy's
five five and he is remarkable his power
his speed his defense
I mean he's hands-down MVP and I don't
know about you all let's do a quick one
okay are you shocked about Girardi no
having been in his business nothing
shocks me and having covered the Yankees
when Billy Martin was there nothing can
shock me I I think that ten years is
probably 15 to 20 years with any other
organization there and it's an
organization that's main changes before
I I think Joe Girardi's actually
underrated underappreciated and maybe
the Yankees gonna find out the hard way
he's a great man if you said my manager
can manage like it's Game seven of the
World Series every game or he doesn't
manage it like it's Game seven the way I
want my manager to care I don't know why
that's such a negative and he didn't
relate to these young players how about
the young players try to relate to Joe
Girardi you know I don't know I I'm
decide right I'm disappointed in it I am
with the Nationals if that family will
pay money and by the way we've got a
great manager in LA Dave Roberts
wonderfully a super person you know but
a great man he may have over managed the
other night but I don't know why he took
some players outing with it but he
utilizes the whole lineup you gotta say
that all right I'm gonna leave you with
this finish this sentence because of the
creation and popularity of social media
journalism has become what worse I think
we were better off with maybe four
networks five networks is on the
News angle sports in coverage I think we
were better with huntley-brinkley
Cronkite
I think things got covered better I
think investigating reporting was better
that we hit the information faster we
did it quicker but it doesn't mean we
get it better but however this I've
learned in my 83 years you can't turn
the clock back it is what it is and
that's what it is
I look we've got a little bit I'm part
of it you're part of it you can't knock
down windmills I will say I do this
though I do not have a sofa I have a
flip phone I make calls receive calls I
don't think I have a way of a need for a
phone you and Bob Costas and Andrew Luck
yes we I think I think hopefully just
gave in and got one a safe travels with
the boys and great to catch up with you
again Larry thank you for joining us
good deal is good thanks that's a Larry
King a longtime Dodger fan legendary
broadcaster been doing it a long time
and the advice that he gave you about
interviewing if this is what you want to
do for a living even if you don't want
to do this for a living if you're a boss
a CEO you manage people knowing how to
ask questions is really important in
getting the answers that you want or you
hope that you're going to get and what
Larry said is what I've preached and was
preached to me quick question get to the
point have the person if you're having
somebody on have them on because you
want to hear what they have to say not
hey let me tell you about me
now you talk and if you want to talk
about me that's even better for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience Channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
you
[Music]